[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
live from New York or Donald Trump has
arrived ahead of becoming the first
former U.S president to face criminal
charges
crowds have been Gathering outside Trump
Tower today as his lawyers asked the
judge to restrict any video from inside
the courtroom tomorrow
also tonight Thomas Cashman is sentenced
to a minimum term of 42 years
Cashman is guilty of murdering Olivia
Pratt Corbell outside Court her mother
talked about her own life sentence a
life without her baby
now everything we do and everywhere we
go was a constant reminder that if she
is not there with us
all I promise for their future so truly
taken away
teachers reject the government's
payoffer and vote overwhelmingly to go
on strike in April and May
[Music]
a woman is arrested in Russia over the
killing of a pro-putin blogger in an
attack on a cafe
oil producers including Saudi Arabia vow
to cut production leading to a surge in
oil prices
[Music]
and the family of a woman who died after
being given medication in hospital for
knee surgery speak to Sky News after an
inquiry finds her death could have been
prevented I was just in complete
disbelief saying how has this possibly
happened just came and we have broken
knee now to the point like she's dying
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
[Music]
thank you
good evening from New York where Donald
Trump is due to face a judge tomorrow
over allegations that he ordered hush
money to be paid to porn actress Stormy
Daniels
it's the first time a former president
has faced criminal charges in this
country
and although we don't know what is in
the indictment now it has been revealed
that there are around 30 counts of
document fraud
or tonight we'll tell you what to expect
in the proceedings tomorrow
plus we'll look at what other legal
challenges Donald Trump is facing and
how it could impact his campaign to run
for the presidency next year
but first our U.S correspondent Mark
Stone as tonight's first report
[Music]
from the gates of his Florida Resort the
former president's motorcade emerging to
make history
this is an extraordinary moment for
America being no doubt about that a
president's long journey from his
Seaside Mansion to a courtroom dock
in this Floridian trumpian Heartland his
supporters were out
[Applause]
but in the numbers he'd hoped for well
his son Eric filming from the Convoy was
spinning it his father's way
[Music]
unbelievable support for Miles he
tweeted
the only Glimpse here of the former
president on the tarmac in Palm Beach
and as he flew his legal team with a new
attorney now among them were putting
together their defense against charges
the details of which they and we do not
yet know
a thousand miles north on New York
City's Fifth Avenue in the shadow of
Trump Tower the homecoming his
supporters had promised was well thin
though they argued otherwise
no I'm not the only one the truth is
that they were outnumbered by police and
by the world's media for America's
deeply partisan cable news this is as
much about ratings as it is about
telling their interpretation at this
moment in American history from his fans
here a pledge that there will be no
trouble this is about supporting a
president wronged a victim of what they
say is a politicized Judiciary and we
know there's not going to be any
violence
[Music]
two blocks to the North in Central Park
beyond the circus a real world view from
three siblings their reflection of this
latest chapter in the Trump story I
think there'll be other more serious
charges prior to the election
between January 6th then the Georgia
stuff the legal system moves so slowly
you know I mean because it's that's set
up that way and he'll use that to his
advantage of course he will yeah
everything's a money money raising
opportunity for him you know so we kind
of
I don't think he won't mind this that
much maybe he's hoping for a perp walk I
don't know of course here you hardly get
a representative snapshot of opinion New
York maybe Trump's home but it's not
where his support is
as he arrived in New York his legal team
was engaged in last-minute arguments
with the court protesting against the
prospect of cameras inside
and then on Fifth Avenue there he was
and so of all the scandals surrounding
Donald Trump in the end it was this that
forced him to court the story of a
president a porn star and a transaction
legal or not
in the day ahead we'll find out the
details and the reaction Across the
Nation stirred and divided Mark Stone
Sky News in Manhattan
Donald Trump traveled here to New York
today this is what will happen over the
next few hours and days
president president Trump's arraignment
the point at which he's told the charges
he faces will take place in a New York
Court from seven o'clock UK time
tomorrow
later that same night the former
president will be flying back to Florida
where he's confirmed he will hold a news
conference at 1 15 a.m UK time
and we'll have live coverage of Donald
Trump's court appearance from 7 P.M
tomorrow here on Sky News
the charges in New York are not the only
legal challenges swirling around Donald
Trump
there are three other ongoing casings
from from Florida our U.S correspondent
Martha Kellner has been looking at the
charges and the impact they could have
on another run at the presidency by
Donald Trump
for Donald Trump's most entrenched
supporters this is simply another cause
to Rally around
he calls it a politically motivated
Witch Hunt and they believe him they're
so frightened of him they don't know
what to do
this is a watershed moment but perhaps
the most remarkable fact is that this is
not even the most serious of the
potential criminal charges that Donald
Trump May face
legal Jeopardy abounds for the former
president not least over an FBI
investigation and raid of his Mar-A-Lago
home officers finding top secret
documents here that had disappeared with
Trump from the White House
a probe is ongoing too into whether he
interfered with a 2020 election count in
Georgia we fight like hell and if you
don't fight like hell you're not going
to have a country anymore
and perhaps most grave of all the
allegation that he incited violence
leading to the January the sixth
storming of the capital I'd say he's in
a mess he's in a heap of trouble some
experts believe this indictment could
prompt charges in other cases now he has
got the label of a criminal defendant in
a in an ongoing prosecution so it may
not be the crime of the century but it
does go to the heart and essence of what
many think he is a fraudster and so once
you get charged the first time I think
it's probably easier on the system
itself
to get charged again
but Trump's legal problems May
conversely be giving him a political
boost polls show his support among
Republican voters is surging the charges
facing Donald Trump do not dissuade
Republican primary voters at all they
rallied some of them to his cause
there's a very small sliver of the
Republican party that views Trump as
problematic or is troubled by these
charges but they already weren't
supporting Donald Trump anyway so it's
really irrelevant
team Trump says he's raised over seven
million dollars in campaign donations in
the five days since his indictment
became public knowledge proved perhaps
that in Trump's world even criminal
charges can be given a positive spin
Martha Kellner Sky News West Palm Beach
it has been quite a day it will be quite
the day tomorrow
that's it from New York for now we'll
have more from here though just before
10 30.
James thank you
Thomas Cashman the man who murdered
nine-year-old Olivia Pratt Corbell will
spend at least 42 years in prison
Cashman did not appear in court today
after refusing to be present for the
sentencing he has always denied any
involvement in the shooting Olivia's
mother gave a statement outside Court in
which he spoke about her chatty girl
being cruelly taken away our crime
correspondent Martin brunt was there and
has this report
she had shed tears in court but outside
Olivia's mother Cheryl was composed in a
tribute to her murdered daughter it was
the lace of Our Lives a sassy chatty
girl who never ran out of energy
she was a character she was my baby and
she has amazing qualities and knew what
she wanted in life
now everything we do and everywhere we
go was a constant reminder that if she
is not there with us
all our promise for their future so
clearly taken away
Olivia's killer Thomas Cashman was given
life with a minimum sentence of 42 years
before any chance of parole by then
he'll be 76. we welcome the sentence
given but what I can say is that my
family and I have already started our
life sentence having to spend the rest
of our lives without Olivia
Cashman was chasing and shooting another
criminal Joseph knee when the fleeing
victim ran into the Corbell house
Cashman kept firing and hit Olivia as
children do Olivia was coming downstairs
to seek reassurance
Cheryl Corbell should have been able to
give that reassurance and to took Olivia
back into bed
what's happened instead was chilling and
strikes fear not only into the immediate
Community but also into the minds of
other children and their parents
shooting into a family home with no
regard for who may be caught in the
crossfire is obviously a very
significant aggravating factor which
must be reflected in the minimum term
Olivia's teenage Sister Chloe read a
personal statement to the court she said
I grieve for what we will never get to
do together I miss sharing my bedroom
with her and hearing her talk all of the
time all the things we should be doing
or would be doing as she got older
confiding in one another shopping
together laughing and making memories
Cashman didn't come into court to hear
his sentence his lawyer said he was
aware that after his conviction last
week Crown prosecutors were overheard
singing the song We Are the Champions
Cashman was concerned the case was
turning into a circus Olivia's Father
John Pratt told the court he had to
leave Liverpool he couldn't cope with
well-meaning people asking him about his
daughter Olivia Pratt Corbell died a
scared nine-year-old and we hope Cashman
is haunted by this knowledge for the
rest of his life
police said they hoped cashman's long
sentence would act as a deterrent to
anyone thinking of picking up a gun and
putting communities at risk Martin brunt
Sky News Manchester Crown Court
teachers have voted to reject the
payoffer by the government today and
will be going ahead with strike action
on the 27th of April and the 2nd of May
the government says the Union's decision
will result in more disruption for
children and less money for teachers
passport office staff began their five
weeks of industrial action today which
could cause severe delays processing
passports
Junior doctors in England will walk out
for four days beginning on April the
11th
10 days of strike action by security
guards at Heathrow Airport is continuing
it ends at midnight on Easter Sunday
more than 130 000 civil servants will
strike on April the 28th and teachers in
England are to hold two more days of
walkouts on April the 27th and also on
May the 2nd Saba Chowdhury has been
speaking to teachers and students
what type of process would actually
require mitochondria here it's crunch
time for these year 11s it may be the
Easter holidays but in five weeks time
they'll be sitting their gcses and so
students unknuckling down they're about
to lose more time because of further
strike action exams are right around the
corner pressure's really mounting but we
are sympathetic to their cause and we do
want teachers to get a higher pay they
should be on strike if they're not
getting the pay they deserve like tea to
them at school they stay until like six
or seven o'clock in the evening
a majority of 98 today voted to reject
the government's latest payoffer calling
it simply unacceptable this generation
so hard hit by kovid the government
should be investing in them trying to
reverse this problem right now so we
regret the disruption towards education
but our action does have a higher moral
purpose
Jillian we need to say to you you are
not reading the room Jillian why do you
think teachers in England are worth less
than teachers in Scotland and Wales
the education secretary Jillian Keegan
says she's extremely disappointed by the
neu's decision to reject her deal one
she says was made in good faith offering
a four and a half percent average pay
rise to teachers a one-off payment of a
thousand pounds and an introduction of
30 grand starting salaries for most
teachers but still not enticing enough
for Mr Islam who says he's so fed up he
wants to pack up teaching entirely at
some point we have to put the workload
impact to one side and our passion to
one side and realize that actually we
can't continue doing this because we're
going to drain ourselves out that's
going to impact the students in the long
term teachers say the strikes are a last
resort and are willing to negotiate with
the government a lot can change in three
weeks Subway choudhary Sky News
a Russian anti-war activist has been
detained accused of being responsible
for an attack on a cafe in Saint
Petersburg Russian officials released a
video showing Daria tripova a 26 year
old woman appearing to take
responsibility for the explosion which
killed a pro-war blogger Skies Moscow
correspondent Diana magnet reports
as investigators picked through the
bombed out remains of the cafe where
military blogger Maxim fomen otherwise
known as vladin tatasky was killed the
hunt was on for this girl Daria trepova
seen here carrying the small statue
thought to be filled with explosives
which she'd presented to tatarski
shortly before the bomb went off
the question is whether the 26 year old
knew what the statue contained she was
detained this morning
in a statement released clearly under
duress she admitted she'd brought the
statue to the cafe but refused to say
who'd given it to her
Russia's investigative committee claims
that trepova was working together with
Ukraine Security Services and with
Alexei navalny's anti-corruption
Foundation which is labeled both as a
foreign agent and an extremist
organization in Russia her husband
believes that she was framed
Street Food Bar number one once belonged
to Wagner boss Evgeni Prego
as he hoisted the flag over the
Ukrainian town of bakmud today claiming
he'd finally captured it he dedicated
the flag to tatasky's memory adding this
in a separate audio message
[Music]
which exists
tatasky will have had many enemies a
former convict originally from maker
near Donetsk he had fought in separatist
battalions against Ukraine since 2014
and as an ultra-nationalist blogger he
did not shy away from criticism of
Russia's military command either
Kiev denies involvement but on the
Russian front lines today his name was
remembered
Sky News Moscow
us officials have confirmed a Chinese
spy balloon that flew over America was
able to transmit sensitive Military
Intelligence in the exclusive Story by
our partners at NBC News it's claimed
that Beijing was able to guide the
device over military sites and send back
information in real time Erasure
correspondent Henry Ann Smith joins us
now from Beijing and Helen and Haber
Beijing responded to these latest
Revelations
they haven't responded yet it's possible
that will come later today uh China time
but look it was only going to be a
matter of time before the Americans were
able to gather up that debris that was
so notably shot down over the ocean and
analyze it and before that analysis hit
the headlines and although this isn't an
official White House release it
nonetheless offers really interesting
detail about what that balloon was
likely doing now our colleagues at NBC
have sourced this to two senior
Administration officials and one former
Administration officials they say the
balloon was actually being controlled
remotely that it took multiple passes
over some of those sensitive military
sites in fact even traveling in a figure
of eight formation which apparently is
quite difficult to do they say that
contrary to a lot of expectation it
wasn't actually taking photographs but
it was gathering intelligence via the
interception of electric signals either
from the weapons themselves down
American bases or from the Personnel on
those bases and crucially that that
information was being sent back to
Beijing in real time intriguingly
apparently there was also a
self-destruct function on that balloon
and for whatever reason that was never
hit and it's not sure whether
um the Chinese decided not to
self-destruct or that that malfunctioned
uh in some way now look the White House
officially has said it can't confirm
these reports but both it and the uh
officials sourced in this story said
that the balloon would have been able to
gather more intelligence were it not for
efforts from the Biden Administration to
sort it to block some of those signals
as I said no response from China yet but
you can expect them to resolutely stick
to that line that this was a civilian
aircraft gathering for weather purposes
that the American moved to shoot it down
was an inflammatory over-reaction it's
worth just taking a step back and
remembering how far things have
deteriorated between the two Nations
since this happened in the early weeks
of February the new details make the
China line slightly harder to sell and
certainly won't repair any relations
between these two major superpowers at
this stage
at the moment thank you lorrate that
response from Beijing
for Linda Allen going into hospital for
knee injury was meant to be a
straightforward procedure but a
complication with her medicine led to
her death Nan inquiry has found her
death could have been prevented our
Scotland correspondent Connor Gillis has
been speaking to her family
she was the best person ever she was a
rock Life Soul of the party just an
amazing person not just to everybody she
was just 59 years old Linda Allen hurt
her knee and got successful surgery here
at this Hospital in Fife back in 2019.
it was the Aftercare where things went
badly wrong when Mom was admitted into
ianie she told them that she didn't take
naproxen and they aren't inflammatory
drug it was documented on her notes that
she no longer takes she was given it
even though our note said yes yes she
was given it yes I was just in complete
disbelief saying how has this possibly
happened just came at me I broke a need
now to the point like she's dying
an inquiry has now ruled Linda's death
could have been prevented after she was
given medication which within hours
reacted with a large stomach ulcer
causing cardiac arrest and multiple
organ failure do you believe this
Hospital killed your mum yes 100 yeah
100 percent and I think because our
paying score had went from 0 to 10 and
we did now in sort of the statements and
things and still not being told then
that my mum was seriously ill she was
there alone with no family which I
really felt feel for her officials in
this inquiry say chances to detect
Linda's deteriorating condition were
missed and the care she received fell
well below the expected standards NHS 5
has accepted a raft of recommendations
to avoid future deaths on their watch I
spoke to mum on the phone whilst I am on
holiday and she told me and I said here
you're going to have to say something
because I know what you like mum and she
was like yeah yeah I promise I said
because if you don't I'm gonna I'm gonna
call the hospital and again another
regret I didn't call the hospital I
didn't call
which is not easy was that one of the
last conversations that you had with
your mum yep
Corner Gillis Sky News
Finland will officially join NATO
tomorrow and become the 31st member of
the alliance NATO Secretary General Jen
soldenberg says it will be a good day
for the country's security and for NATO
Russia said it will strengthen its
military capacity along its border with
Finland
it's not for Moscow to decide who is
going to be a member of NATO or not it's
for the applicant countries and for NATO
to decide and this is very clearly
demonstrated here at the NATO
headquarters tomorrow when we raise the
Finnish flag and finalize the Finnish
accession process
tributes are being paid to the former
conservative Chancellor Nigel Lawson
who's died at the age of 91. he was
Chancellor in Margaret Thatcher's
government from 1983 to
1989. the current prime minister Rishi
sunak said one of the first things he
did when he became Chancellor was to
hang Nigel Lawson's picture above his
desk
Timothy Scofield who's the brother of
the television presenter Philip
Schofield has been found guilty of
sexually abusing a child during the
trial the jury heard Timothy Scofield
had told his brother Philip he'd watch
pornography with the boy when he was
over the age of 16. today the TV
presenter said if any crime had been
confessed to him he would have acted
immediately to protect the victim
Global oil prices are jumped today after
some of the world's major producers
announced a cut to production Brent
crude the international oil Benchmark
jumped more than five percent this
morning following the announcement our
climate and energy correspondent Hannah
Thomas Peter can explain more
the price of oil matters because it
impacts the cost of everything from
consumer goods to manufacturing and to
fuel making it a key driver of inflation
that's why this group of 13 Nations
known as OPEC short for the organization
of petroleum exporting countries is so
influential they're often joined by 10
other oil producing Nations including
Russia this group is referred to as OPEC
plus and produces about 40 percent of
the world's crude oil their supply
relative to Global demand has a huge
impact on price so let's take a look at
this graph showing the price per barrel
of Brent crude oil over the last three
years just to see a few examples so this
is when kovid hit back in early 2020 the
world shut down meaning a huge slump in
demand and a collapse in price by
contrast this is when Russia invaded
Ukraine early last year and there was
concern about an oil shortage sending
the price well above 100 twenty dollars
per barrel since then there's generally
speaking been weaker demand from China
and fears of a global economic
contraction but on Sunday there was a
bit of a surprise Saudi Arabia Iraq and
several Gulf States or unexpectedly
announced they would cut Supply by more
than a million barrels a day and the
result Brent crude up by more than five
percent but for some this isn't just
about price it's about power and Saudi
Arabia defying America's request to keep
Supply steady
if a decision is taken by one of the
largest producers in their let's say
Saudis and and the other countries from
the cartel are taken on board then this
is basically the major bulk of the
market is able to move in concert and
there is very little in terms of
political or Market leverage
um the other oil producers can do and
there is also very little that all
consumers can do aside from actually
doubling down and reducing over all the
all demand
but that might be challenging even with
the global push to decarbonize there are
predictions that world oil demand is
likely to accelerate sharply this year
as air travel rebounds and China opens
up again after covet
welcome back to New York where Donald
Trump will hear what criminal charges he
is facing tomorrow here at Trump Tower
crowds of supporters of the former
president have been Gathering all day as
he traveled from his home in Florida to
this city by calling Mark Stone joins me
now Mark details are pretty fit on the
ground about how tomorrow will play out
in court but we have learned something
yeah I mean it's worth remembering that
none of us really knows what these
charges are plenty of people have
already said that this is a Witch Hunt
uh that this shouldn't have come this
far legally but no one actually knows
the details of this of this the grand
jury which which whose job is a little
bit like our own prosecution service
they decide whether or not there is
enough to press charges they decided
that there was enough but we don't know
what that is and we will discover more
over the course of the next day or so
but yes there are legal arguments
ongoing they're making this up as they
go along there's an argument right now
about whether or not cameras will be
allowed in court will we get to see
Donald Trump in the courtroom at the
moment no but there is a push by the
American Media for that to happen Donald
Trump's lawyers interestingly do not
want that to happen some might have
thought that he would want to make a
spectacle of this it's looking as though
he does not want that so so that's
interesting the argument that his
lawyers are using is that it would make
a circus of all of this well I have to
say today it's already looking like a
bit of a circus a word briefly on his
supporters I don't think there have been
that many here in New York there was a
call for uh for many to join uh to come
here as a Sort of Homecoming this of
course is his City but his support base
is not here it was never here down in
Mar-A-Lago in Florida not many people
there either I think that's interesting
we'll see how many turn up tomorrow
Marjorie Taylor green is a congresswoman
one of his key supporters she is will be
here tomorrow she's calling for many
many people to come we'll see Mark Stone
hey thanks
angle history in a criminal court in New
York's Berry has never been a criminal
case against the former U.S president in
Manhattan's District Courthouse there
never has been anywhere as Donald Trump
spends the evening in his apartment on
the top floor of Trump Tower the
unprecedented president knows he will be
the first when they call the case his
case
people of the state of New York against
Donald J Trump
well that was Guy News at 10 coming up
we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
newspapers in the Press previewed
including this story on the front of the
Metro after the jailing of Thomas
Cashman for the murder of Libya Pratt
Court Bell their headline gutless
tonight we're joined by the journalist
and a broadcaster Jenny kleeman and the
political editor of the Daily Telegraph
Ben Reilly Smith do stay with us for
more
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign